it's always great when this man calls
into the show and i get to work with him
i missed him at the combine i missed him
he is the voice of my 40-yard dash so i
missed that too
he is charles davis of cbs sports and my
compadre from the nfl
network how are you cd i'm doing better
now that i'm hearing your voice rich
because
there was a void there's a hole there
the 40-yard dash
yeah and believe me you know we can joke
all we want we can be somewhat
tongue-in-cheek
we know the incredible work you've done
thank you
with st jude's and why that why you're
40 significant and people all over the
world are running 40s
been different but it's one of the
greatest phenomenons i've ever seen
well charles there's some there's
something special we got cooked up for
this year charles
i can't wait i can't wait that is i
missed i missed calling it i missed
being there
being a part of it doing that seeing how
the whole thing has evolved and i've
told you this privately
rich that what you have done with your
heart
is the biggest part of all of this
because yeah that was a fun little thing
but look what you've turned it into
and who's being helped along the way and
to be able to talk about that i've
missed that and the last thing i'll say
yes sir i have heard from plenty of
people who have said
you know i missed the combine but god i
really missed run rich run i thought
don't worry
it's coming it is it's coming it is it's
going to be in a different different
place
it's going to be part of it's going to
be part of our third day of the draft
coverage
um and something special on that front
is going down this very weekend here in
los angeles i don't want to say anything
because it hasn't
you know if if you will happen it's not
in the can as they say yet
in the uh yeah in the uh the los angeles
world where we're going to be doing it
so
that's common i can't wait to show you
and tell everyone once once that's
actually
because it's really special we're very
excited about it and that wasn't the
royal we it's the bunch of people that
are running this year
so we'll just uh put a pin in that and
just turn to the actual draft right now
charles we just uh hung up with uh david
shaw
who you know was he's i love i just love
the way that he uh evaluates i just love
the way that he's so even keel
and he was exactly that talking about
the quarterbacks
and then when i mentioned kyle pitts
gents am i wrong
when i mentioned kyle pitts it went it
totally like
it went up it went off the charts
and so where what do you think of kyle
pitch we had on yesterday got a chance
to meet
boy did he sound like he's got
everything going in the right direction
everything is in fact pointed up with
him charles yeah there's no question
about that
and my first thought was every day you
know everything you said about david
shaw
spot on i worked at stanford rich when
david was a student athlete there
so that tells you where i am in in my
point in life right now
and to see him doing all the great
things he's doing and he was a receiver
so you know how it is your former you
know what your former life was sometimes
you'll elevate a little bit more for
those people
and kyle pitts is that guy it may say
tight end next to his name he's really a
receiver
so i think that that helps as well and
when i talk with people i'm very close
to a florida
they can't say enough things and one
thing that keeps sticking out
is this everything you see on tape with
him
we saw every day
it wasn't just you know he he elevated
and created and did
they said every day any practice that
way
and one of the great comments i got from
someone there is
we would pull him back to save him from
himself
because every snap for him was a
competition
and he wasn't about to get beat so i i
thought that spoke volumes about kyle
pitt so what do you think the falcons
should do
because we had thomas dimitrov on last
week he's the guy that gave matt ryan
the contract
that he said was intended to keep him
there for the rest of his career
and he said even that that you have to
address the quarterback position when
you're drafting this high
that said we just hung up from david
shaw
who said you can't pass up he's he's
like i'm speaking as a coach here
because normally when you get a
developmental quarterback prospect
usually somebody other than you is going
to be the one winding up coaching that
quarterback that's drafted
that he's right you can't pass up pits
with
ryan and jones and ridley
and you go to work that way what do you
say about that fourth overall spot
charles i'm glad i'm not having to pick
and if i were sold on the quarterback i
take the quarterback because we're
starting the next era
for atlanta as much as i don't want to
turn down kyle pitts
we're starting that next era and whoever
this young quarterback is
rich you know matt ryan and sometimes
when we talk
there is some hyperbole that goes into
things but is there any way possible
that a young quarterback can't have a
good experience sitting behind matt ryan
for a year
because i don't care who you are matt
ryan could
walk in every day and tell himself i'm
not treating this kid great i'm going to
be a jerk
i'm doing everything he can't do it
right it's not who he is
he can't do it so it's a great spot for
that because i think you're fast
forwarding
but if you convince yourself that matt
ryan and you want to go forward and you
take pits
i get it but here's my here's my caveat
rich here's my devil's advocate
they already score points
this is not an atlanta team that doesn't
score points this is not atlanta team
that doesn't put up
big numbers on that the defensive side
of ball's getting them killed
so fourth pick people coming for pits
do you parlay that into some more things
and go
i don't want to talk out of both sides
of my mouth but i will say this if you
are wavering on the quarterback
then i would say i would suggest you go
to plan b which is either pits
or the defensive side of the ball and
get those extra picks
that's where i'm looking but if you have
the conviction go get your quarterback
and because i think you're starting
right now
and by defensive side of the ball get
your picks you mean trading out for
somebody who wants to trade it out
before
you have somebody somebody's gonna want
pits heck cincinnati
well they'd rarely do things like that
but one spot
you know but i'm just saying somebody's
going to want to come up and get that
young man
because you know david shaw is bouncing
off the walls everyone is
he's that generational type of a guy
i'll pause it to you this way
evan ingram that's what the giants were
expecting or
are still kind of expecting what we're
seeing kyle pitts do right now
that type of speed dynamic ability got
to catch the football obviously and i'm
hoping evan ignorance could have that
type of a bounce back because
he's a heck of a talent too pitts is the
next iteration of what we're talking
about
charles davis here on the rich eisen
show who do you think the 49ers gave up
all that draft capital to go get
at three everybody keeps telling me mac
jones
i think that they are going to play this
thing out rich
you got two more pro lance got another
one scheduled
i don't think that's by accident as well
i think this is the 49ers being able to
do their due diligence and what i love
they're going to put them through 49ers
type drills see what they're getting
have a full comparison
if it's me all things being equal and
it's a weird year rich because we're not
nearly as close to these young men as we
kind of
are during most years right so the
niners no
more than we do and i don't mind saying
that and they typically do it but this
year it's even more so
i i think fielder lance runs that
offense the same way
or or even better than what we're
talking about with mac jones
but there's something in there that if
the 49ers are saying it's mac jones
the way that shanahan wants it to be run
and how he thinks is processed
and just look back through through the
past i go back to matt ryan again
remember the year before matt ryan's mvp
year in kyle shanahan i don't know that
they
had a true meeting of the minds yet it
was a little rocky
but matt worked at it worked out it
worked out improved his athleticism got
his flexibility
turned into an nfl mvp mac jones can do
the same thing
let's just say charles davis that it is
um
mac jones chosen three and the falcons
decide you know what we can't pass up on
pits and the bengals are like we are
totally gonna hook burro up
with his old receiver jamar chase and
then the dolphins are like you know what
we're absolutely going to get to a an
old weapon
from alabama choose one uh for him
and then you've got the lions sitting
there at seven
with a chance to get lance or fields
do you think they should do that even
though they went ahead and got golf you
would huh
i would and and here's the reason why
yeah you put it into golf
but you don't know you did you didn't
make that deal because you were
you were set saying that he's my guy
going forward
you make the deal because you think you
can improve your team overall
and it was just time for matthew
stafford and you kind of you know did
him a solid
i get all of that but if you've got this
guy sitting there
that you again we have to do this thing
we always have to keep in mind
is this who you have conviction on as a
franchise as a as a scouting group
and brad holmes comes from l.a and saw
the goth thing happen
that doesn't mean that he's flat-out
sold that he's his guy going forward
i would definitely take a hard look
there or i'd make sure my phone line was
open because they could very easily trap
you know move back as well and improve
their football team because now you got
denver in there
you know you got washington in there
you've got you know
if new orleans really gonna make that
bold move remember that what year was it
rich when they came all the way up and
went to 12. we all thought it was a
quarterback
they took uh davenport in the fast rush
yeah we thought it was lamar jackson
that was going to go to new england
we were looking at each other like okay
is this is this the moment
quarterback you know yeah i know we
thought new orleans was going to go
uh it was going to go right then and
there to to get lamar and we're like is
this the moment
you know and uh i remember that so you
know
that's a fascinating thing because if if
lance and fields are somehow on the
board sitting there at seven and we've
got dan campbell on tomorrow's show the
new coach of the
lions carolina we all know just got sam
darnold you know i mean would that be
like denver's dream scenario to have
only to trade up a couple of spots
that's one thing i'm going to ask
schlereth too because
the number of times that you hear that
that elway's looking to upgrade from
drew locke
uh even though elway keeps saying that
he loves drew lock i've lost track
you know what i'm saying so yeah yeah
dalton reisner talked about it his
offensive lineman and
he's really pumping up lock he i think
riser went what one pic before lock in
the draft
and he's really been talking about to
talk about how much he's been spending
time with peyton manning
trying to you know get it out there that
this kid's coming and he's rising and
what have you
i don't think that would deter denver if
one of those quarterbacks was sitting
there
see i look at trey lance and i see josh
allen
all the same questions about josh allen
are coming up about trey lance you see
that body type that big arm
everybody talks about accuracy we all
thought you can't improve accuracy as
much as
josh allen has done in the nfl is either
going to be the total unicorn
or if we've been missing the boat the
kids can get better and more accurate if
given the right time
coaching and ability we'll see so let's
say
charles davis a couple more minutes left
with you i love this sort of stuff i
love this talk you and i know you do too
um that lance is sitting out there or
fields is sitting out there bottom of
the top ten and there's new england
sitting there at 15 and
that's close that's close enough hailing
distance i could see belichick saying
you know they
he loves these guys or he's intrigued by
these guys
right but not enough to get up to four
right
not enough to go up to four not enough
to go up into seven for detroit or eight
for carolina but
you know tens more you you're you know
you're trying out on for size
do you think new england like that free
agency bill could show up on draft night
and be draft night bill and just go
completely against brand and type and
just go for it
like this i don't i don't think there's
any question about it
and here's why two things come to mind
bill belichick is going to be how old
now 69.69
yep so look he's a smart man right how
many more years do you want to be in on
the grind
and get ready and go for it right not
many george hallas is running around
and remember papa bear stepped away
three times and kept coming back
so it was different it kind of
rejuvenated the second part is
have we not heard the owner of the new
england patriots multiple times talk
about their bad drafts in recent years
and we need to do something different
i don't think that i don't think i don't
take that rich and just throw it aside
there's a different feel a different
vibe coming out of there and here's the
thing i want to throw at you
what if mac jones doesn't get taken at
three
and they take fields or lands right and
matt jones is sitting there
in that spot with fields or
lance and new england has a chance to
take a guy
see a lot of people see that as a lock
for mac jones and i don't
because new england signed cam and then
resigned camp
they're willing to play it differently
now it's not there's not hey let's get
our tom brady look-alike clone
that's not a lock so that would be very
interesting to me if one of those
athletic quarterbacks is sitting there
with matt jones
i wouldn't make it a lock if new england
wanted to make a move
last one for you charles davis how do
you think sam darnold works with
carolina
and how do you think that is going to
work they picked up his fifth year
option or going to
pick up his fifth year option which i'm
wondering if they would not do if they
do decide to go get a quarterback
at uh eighth overall which would kind of
surprise me now
because darnold's 23 for crying out loud
so go to work with
with him i'd imagine what do you think
of that maneuver
yeah he's 23 and remember scott federer
who's taking over the gm he's the one
who's carrying the big grade
to help make that move right he's the
one because matt rule wasn't in the
league at that time he was at baylor
so you know you know you you go through
all that here's what i think
i think he plays better i don't think
there's any question in my mind
offensive line they still got some work
to do there greg little's not a lock for
me at left tackle so let's see what they
do with that
but look at the weapons outside dj moore
robbie anderson you get mccaffrey back
i think he's got a much better
supporting cast around him
that allows him to get comfortable and
look more like the sam darnold that was
drafted
as opposed to the guy that you know
jokes were made about that weren't
always accurate
there's he showed flashes i think he's
got a much better
chance at doing this now but i do think
that carolina's gonna have to not just
draft defense this year
you better draft some people around him
and to me a left tackle's probably
a priority because i'm not just
penciling in greg little and saying
that's my guy
what tv show you're watching these days
charles what are you watching
well you know me yellowstone i'm waiting
for yellowstone to come back
okay very good that's your you love that
show right
uh i love that show though well you know
you know i'm a billions guy i always
have been a billions guy
i worked that night that was one of my
favorite nights ever yeah
so i tried yeah i mean especially with
especially when you told me ahead of
time
i worked blue a little bit i did i
worked blue and they chose not to put it
in there i thought i gave him a nice
little gift a nice little easter egg to
work blue
um but i didn't do it i didn't make the
final that my i guess they were had my
back for me
i don't know and you know i'm crazy
about them the only thing i've got
and i'd love to i want to meet mr
coppelman and the rest of the crew
was how did they mess up the al davis
quote
which one was that god the guy who was
dating taylor
the billionaire guy who was dating
taylor right he
he said it's just like the oakland
raiders and al davis win baby win i said
what what i came off my couch just made
me win just win baby yeah
normally that's what baby wins they
never mess those things up they nailed
those quotes
they absolutely nailed them i don't know
how that one slid through i was a little
that that one knocked me off my couch i
know you're a big harlan cobin guy i had
a great chat
with him on my podcast just getting
started charles he's not the best
he's a good dude man he is he is he is
absolutely the best and one of the
greatest moments i've had as a
broadcaster he stayed in the booth with
me for a jet skin no kidding
jets rams when fisher was with the rams
um bryce petty started a quarterback for
the jet oh my gosh
an abysmal game middle i turn around
early second quarter on a break yeah you
doing okay
and he said hey dude just want to let
you know this is great
my god this game is awful
yeah i couldn't argue with it yes you
know he's got a way with words
charles the man has always worked does
he ever second
what would he say in his fraternity
second most sold uh author in his own
fraternity
dan brown that's right dan brown was in
his fraternity too
um and hey a great season with iron
eagle you're such a terrific list and
the two of you are perfect thank you
with each other he's phenomenal isn't he
he is he's absolutely phenomenal
thank you rich i can't wait to see you
in cleveland i look forward to it you
take care charles
you do say best of the family yep you
bet same to you charles davis cbs sports
and see him in cleveland hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here